welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and black panther wakanda forever
just dropped its first trailer at san
diego comic con i have so many questions
about this movie they announced that
tanaka huerta is going to be playing
neymar the submariner dominique thorne
is going to be playing iron heart rear
michaela cole is gonna be playing a
character we all have a ton of questions
on how they're gonna handle the passing
of chadwick boseman and just so you know
this is gonna be the first of many black
panther wakana forever videos we'll be
doing here on new rock stars be sure to
also watch our break room live stream
with jessica clements zach cuddleston
eric wussu and john costa they did an
amazing job reacting to this panel
moment by moment i'm also going to do a
breakdown of all the major highlights
that we learned from this panel and my
in-depth frame by frame breakdown of
this black panther trailer all the
easter eggs and details that you missed
is gonna be coming monday i'm gonna need
some time with this one i think but
let's take a look black panther wakand
forever here we go
that looks like a
pyramid what is this a mexican coast
[Music]
oh why is she on
wow so they're just
they're gonna show it white robes mean a
funeral attire right good friends
but it's still a celebration
oh wow
this music is just so beautiful i'm
sorry to be talking over it
the footage just looks so beautiful
oh wow
oh my gosh
whoa
whoa is this the birth of neymar the wow
i mean obviously they'd be water births
but they're i can't believe they show
that in marvel trailer
he looks amazing the headdress is just
beautiful
oh they're mixing it in with the
whoa
also looks like human intervention
the colonizers
oh my god it's flooded
they're doing it they are flooding
wakanda
whoa
what is frozen over what are we seeing
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god they're actually flooding it
whoa holy [ __ ]
oh my god
oh whoa
[Applause]
oh my god i need a second i i straight
up just need a second with this
wow
wow
wow
wow
i'm not ready for this movie to be
honest with you i'm not uh i'm not ready
i'm not ready i know normally with our
reactions is just kind of me screaming
and falling out of my chair and looking
like an idiot uh it's it's rare to have
a trailer hit me like this yes while it
it seems like the end of a lot of things
but it also seems like the beginning i
mean let's keep in mind that this is
going to just be the the end of phase
four uh but immediately after it uh
ant-man and the monson maybe it's gonna
be the beginning of phase five and we're
in the midst of a multiverse saga so
while this may be the end of a version
of wakanda i think it's gonna be the
beginning of something new i mean who
knows with secret wars kang dynasty
coming down the pipeline i wouldn't be
surprised if we got a complete reset of
of the country of wakanda now yeah it
looks like this movie is going to show
us the the death of the character of
t'challa in the 616 mcu they have not
shown us yet how he is going to die but
whatever they plan to do with the
character of t'challa in the future of
the mcu i really really hope the
character has a future we still needed
this movie to say goodbye to chadwick
bozeman and it seems like they're
handling it really really well and
really respectfully so here's what i'm
able to derive it looks like there's
some james cameron-esque human
intervention group of uh submarine and
sub-aquatic explorers who have stumbled
upon the kingdom of atlantis tanaka
huerta is playing neymar the submariner
who is we should note technically
marvel's first mutant it'll be
interesting in this movie if they call
him a mutant i assume they have to at
this point that's one thing that we did
not hear at this panel is any mention of
mutants i assume all of that will come
in d23 in september because there are a
lot of slots in marvel's phase six
timeline that they just haven't filled
in yet thanks to honeygain for
sponsoring this video honeygain is an
app that makes you cash just for keeping
it running in the background they're not
promising to pay all of your bills or
anything but this enough money to cover
your netflix subscription every month or
maybe buy you and a friend some tasty
beverages here's how it works you just
install honey gain on your device and
that's it you're making money just by
sharing your internet connection it uses
the internet to gather bits of
information from the web like the best
prices on airline tickets honey game
doesn't have any effect on your internet
experience or collect any personal data
or require any device storage and
whenever you have twenty dollars
withdraw your money to paypal or bitcoin
and go buy your buddy that beverage
they're thirsty you can also withdraw
into a jmpt cryptocurrency it works on
windows mac os and android devices and
about a month ago we announced a
giveaway and now it is time to see who
won 50 dollars worth of funny game
credits drumroll please
the winner is the honey game user whose
referral code is den
666 fe congrats
666 fe you'll have that money added to
your account today for the rest of you
use code new rockstars 5 when signing up
or click the link in the description
down below to get five dollars added to
your account but it looks like these
human soldiers are targeting both the
atlanteans and the wakandans you can
imagine both of these civilizations have
access to advanced technology including
vibranium a very precious resource on
earth and this is going to lead to a
disastrous conflict between these
societies really the most famous
conflict between the wakandans and the
atlanteans in the marvel comics is the
2012 avengers versus x-men storyline in
which neymar floods wakanda with a tidal
wave now wakanda is in the middle of the
african continent you may wonder how was
he able to get an ocean tidal wave well
there is a body of water next to it i
would imagine neymar if not some other
atlantean might be a water bender the
trailer transitioned so smoothly from
bob marley's no woman no cry to kendrick
lamar's all right both songs have
powerful powerful connections to protest
movements but also in this context
try to tackle the impossible task of
trying to comfort us but also energize
us help us grieve help us process the
use of the music throughout the 2018
black panther was such a core part of
that story and now in this trailer
they're even using these songs to just
kind of reassure us to comfort us to
help us mourn the most powerful line in
this trailer was ramona just screaming i
am the queen of the most powerful nation
in the world and my entire family is
gone interesting for her to say her
entire family obviously tachaka and
t'challa are gone but what does that
mean for shuri what happens to shuri in
this movie is she gonna be missing is
she gonna be kidnapped in exile somehow
from wakanda this final shot of the
trailer positioned shuri in a new black
panther suit i at least i assume this is
shuri it seems like they're deliberately
keeping that a mystery for now of course
because this armor is black and gold
this really could just be a resurrected
form of killmonger and thor eleven
thunder we learned how things like
valhalla allow for perhaps resurrections
or reincarnations and killmonger might
be in the ancestral plane currently
maybe they found a way to resurrect him
and bring him back into this plane now
it's interesting to note how the
atlanteans in this movie are depicted as
blue skinned whereas tanakh huerta as
namor is not that could be a factor of
his mutation there are also rumors that
atuma is going to be in this movie he's
one of neymar's villains from the skarka
tribe exiled from atlanta it's part of a
prophecy to try to destroy atlantis and
we got a brief shot of riri williams
iron heart hammering out the heart from
her armor it sounds like she's going to
be an mit student who gets recruited and
now it looks like she's going to be
working alongside shuri in the wakandan
lab it looks like the character of namor
is going to be attached to aztec
mythology we see some aztec art in the
depictions of the aztec guards there was
a mention of quetzalcoatl from thor love
and thunder 30 seconds there's an
interesting shot of like the dora milaje
standing in front of uh different icons
and images one on the far left shows
like a tree with roots mirroring its
branches can't help but connect that at
least visually to yidracil the world's
tree of asgardian mythology there's just
so much symbolism iconography uh visual
details i just can't wait to break down
frame by frame and there's so much more
to talk about from this trailer but one
question i think we should all be asking
is who is behind this group of undersea
explorers is it james cameron probably
not some other human villain is gonna be
funding this expedition okay there is uh
so much to break down from this weekend
i am going to break down all the major
news the release dates the phases where
this is all headed in another video
coming out next tonight on the channel
my breakdown of this black panther
wakanda forever trailer coming monday on
the channel and then the days weeks and
months ahead we're gonna be unpacking
the rest of it and what it all means for
the marvel cinematic universe follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos
following rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you